yeah
[Music]
it's PS plus time again the mid-month
update which adds a bunch of games to
the extra and premium tiers every game
you see on this video will be available
from the 18th of October a total of 23
games we've got a lot to get through so
let's do this first up is GTA
GTA the definitive
on PS4 and PS5 one of the greatest PS2
games ever made has been updated for a
new audience upgrades to lighting
textures and the controls have been
modernized too we play as Tommy versetti
who gets out of prison in the 1980s and
is tasked with starting a new Venture in
Vice City which is GTA's version of
Miami 20 years ago this was a
groundbreaking game with a sprawling
open world 87 missions and side tasks to
get through and all fully voiced as well
oh and it had one of the greatest
soundtracks you'll ever hear if you like
80s and 90s music that is the definitive
edition is by no means a remake just an
update to let us experience Tommy's
Journey to the top all over again yet
another Assassin's Creed game is here
this time it's Odyssey this action RPG
is built on the foundations of Origins
which we got last month and takes us to
Greece in 400 BC the story does a great
job of blending real life events and the
mythology of the time to give an
experience like no other and it can be
played Through The Eyes of two
characters a male and female you'll be
climbing and exploring as you always do
in these games and look you can even
hang on to a statue's junk what more
could you want the combat once again
lets the player decide what weapon to
choose and the constant drip feeding of
better equipment is the hook which never
lets go the average playthrough is 40
hours long and if you're a completionist
you're going to spend over 120 hours
achieving your goals this world is
humongous there are also five more
Assassin's Creed games added this month
there are smaller 2.5 d games Assassin's
Creed Chronicles China India and Russia
they are more like mobile games in their
Simplicity and ease of use and take
about three hours to complete each
adding more law to the long line of
Assassin's Creed games then there's full
size Assassin's Creed games Assassin's
Creed 3 remastered is set during the
American Revolution we follow Conor as
he tries to find his way in the American
colonies as both the Native American and
the son of a British Templar AC3 was
made quite a long time ago so don't
expect the same Variety in weapons but
there are a few brawls in there and it
still had stealth sequences back then
too and there's another one Assassin's
Creed Syndicate takes the series to
London in the 1800s as Jacob and Evie
Embrace their sibling rivalry and
they're pulled in two different
directions to liberate London or to
discover ancient tombs and take their
Bounty so what do they do they do both
and they also meet Charles Darwin too
that's a lot of Assassin's Creed games
next something spooky for the Halloween
month the medium a psychological Horror
in which we live in Two Worlds
simultaneously the everyday life you and
I are in right now and the spirit realm
where everything is filled with things
that make you on edge and nervous the
draw to the medium is to freely move
between worlds and an act in one world
affects the other world two Realms
connected the puzzles are designed to
have you hopping between realities
regularly as you escape a monster like
no other the story takes between 7 and 9
hours to complete through reviews are
all over the place which is the norm for
horror games either the atmosphere works
for you or it doesn't so you're gonna
have to try it to see what you think
next we have a crazy amount of Dragon
Quest games to get through all in vastly
different genres first Dragon Quest
Builders and Dragon Quest Builders 2.
Dragon Quest is a Japanese RPG in its
roots but this brings that into the
world of Minecraft and carves a single
player RPG Adventure which is
surprisingly good you wake up in the
world with one key skill building you're
the only one who can do it as you
venture further away from home you'll
meet other people with different skills
and without realizing you're suddenly
running a small town and managing the
villagers here and keeping them safe at
night like a true Guardian Builders 2
takes this concept further and refines
the RPG elements and sets you free with
building Blueprints and structures
however you like both games were loved
by reviewers with many 9 out of 10
scores so if you need to get your
Minecraft building fixed but you also
want a story give Dragon Quest builders
ago on the flip side there are two more
Dragon Quest games called Heroes they
have a similar title yet Dragon Quest
heroes are completely hack and slash
games you are given a team of four
Heroes who can be switched between
freely and then you run through worlds
wrecking everything and everyone in
sight if anyone stands before you you're
gonna take them down to get the most out
of Heroes you'll need to know some
Dragon Quest Basics as the context of a
fight will hit different if you're a
real fan compared to someone who hasn't
got a clue like me and then Heroes 2
once again refines the mechanics and has
a considerably higher review score than
its predecessor and wait there's more
Dragon Quest this time Dragon Quest 11.
okay this one actually is a jrpg it's
the only one with turn-based combat it
allows for thought to be put into each
attack tactically satisfying I think
they call that each enemy fights
differently and more often than not a
unique approach is needed to battle each
one of them this then tests your
Tactical skill when more than one type
of enemy team up if you want to get a
full dose of Dragon Quest law 11 is the
best to start with out of the five games
it's also the longest about 70 hours of
time will be needed to get through this
story and this world Dragon Quest 11 on
Metacritic has a 91 out of 100 rating
okay let's move away from saying Dragon
Quest for the 100th time in this video
take a look at inside an amazing puzzle
platformer that tells a compelling story
through actions no words are ever spoken
no context is ever given yet the
narrative is always with you avoiding
guards blending in with other people and
using a freaking mind control helmet
come for the puzzles stay for the story
inside is amazing it's become a norm
that we get an anime game each month
this time it's Naruto to boruto Shinobi
Striker a brawler that was previously on
PS Plus in June if it looks a bit
familiar for Shinobi's fight another
four shinobis it's that simple if you
want it to be from there it's about
mastering moves and Combos and also wall
running and zip lining and dodging they
all play important parts in each fight
the real match history though comes with
combining multiple fighting styles into
one character and finally hohokum rounds
out the games on the extra tier which is
close to impossible to explain but I'll
try we are a kite that flies through
multiple worlds discovering new people
and helping them with mundane tasks
you'll be at a wedding one minute then
helping a mermaid find her way home then
a roller coaster World it sounds insane
and if you're into these kind of things
look out for it on October 18th but wait
there is even more let's go to the
premium games this month Yakuza 3 4 and
5 all remastered on PS4 arrive this
month Kiryu earned his retirement then
becomes an orphanage Patron and must
juggle his new position with being a
former gangster he is then joined by
multiple protagonists in Yakuza 4 like a
loan shark and a corrupt cop and finally
in Yakuza 5 he tries to find peace
between his clan and the alliance Kyu
has been through a lot and it'll take
around 100 hours to progress through
those three stories so good luck if you
choose to do it we just looked at inside
and their Dev team made another
magnificent game before that one limbo
and it's here in the premium tier
another puzzle platformer with no
talking at all we enter limbo and try to
find our little sister but this place is
filled with creatures who Feast on
children if we survive all the way to
the end we find out what really happened
to the brother and sister and it'll
stick in your mind for the rest of your
life but the PS3 games that have been
added in the month of October are Ultra
Street Fighter 4 with 44 fighters to
choose from in the typical one-on-one
format we have Castlevania Lord of
Shadows a third person action adventure
which reimagines the mythology of
Castlevania and finally game 23 everyday
shooter super simple mini games you may
have seen in the arcades in the 1970s
like asteroids we did it 23 games I'm
Adam you're awesome it's been a pleasure
peace